[Music]
we start here at noon with some breaking
news the nevada state athletic
commission breaking its silence after a
story the i-team first broke unlv
student nathan valencia died four days
after participating in a fraternity
boxing match as the i-team first
reported valencia's family their
attorney and witnesses say there was no
professional medical help and there was
no professional referee at the event
vanessa murphy here with more on what
the athletic commission is now saying
vanessa
heather the nevada state athletic
commission is blaming unlv saying the
university knew about the fraternity
boxing match weigh-in was held on campus
and it's been a tradition for about a
decade the chairman insists the
commission had no jurisdiction for the
event but he says the commission can and
will investigate what went wrong
this is nathan valencia he would have
turned 21 years old last saturday
instead his parents tell me he passed
away from head injuries four days after
the fight he participated in the event
for charity which according to social
media posts was held by the kappa sigma
fraternity he is seen here in the red
headgear he collapsed after the fight
athletic commission chairman stephen
klubeck points the finger at unlv
with regard to
the university
having knowledge of this and accepting
and allowing this well go speak with the
university and the board of regents
they got a lot of explaining to do in my
opinion
they cannot duck hide bob and weave on
this
valencia's death ruled a homicide by the
clark county coroner due to blunt force
injuries to the head chairman klubeck
says metro police should investigate
this as a homicide the department
announced yesterday it investigated
licensing and the sahara event center
where it was held is not at fault a unlv
spokesman tells me the university is
looking into the incident i asked for an
interview with unlv's president the
spokesman responded saying because the
review is ongoing no additional
information will be shared now the
i-team broke this story five days ago
and still no leadership from unlv has
agreed to an interview